Greetings to my 3ABN family, and welcome
[music] to another 3ABN Today Bible Q&A.
My name is Ricky Carter, and I'll be
your host today. Well, we've got another
hour-packed program with your Bible
questions, and we have the answers found
right here in the word of God, and of
which our panel will be giving us those
sharing with us those answers. So, let
me introduce you to our panel straight
away. Next to me, to my right, I have my
brother Ian Vanderbok. Welcome, brother.
Hey, Ricky. Thank you for having me.
Pleasure to be here. Great to have you
here. Next to him, we have Pastor John
Dinzey. Welcome, brother. Thank you.
It's a blessing to be here, and uh Bible
Q&A is a program where we all learn.
Amen. Amen. And next to Pastor, we have
my brother Darrell Thomas. Welcome,
brother. Thank you. Uh pleasure to be
here with my brothers in Christ. Amen.
Amen.
Well, before we go to the word of God,
why don't we open up
His word with a prayer from Pastor
Dinzey. Could you lead us, please? Yes.
Let's go to the Lord in prayer.
Our loving heavenly Father, we thank you
so much for the holy scriptures.
Thank you, Lord, that we have access to
them in many different ways today. We
ask, Lord, for the blessing of your Holy
Spirit that as we speak, you will speak
through us.
And we pray for also for your children
listening, that your Holy Spirit will
help them to understand [music] and help
us to understand. Give us, Lord, the
message your children need to hear.
>> [music]
>> And Lord, we thank you for the
scriptures that are able to make us wise
unto salvation.
We thank you, Lord, for 3ABN. We pray
that you will continue to bless this
ministry to continue broadcasting the
everlasting gospel 24 hours a day around
the world. We ask you for these things
in the holy and blessed [music] name of
Jesus.
Well, Darrell, I've got your first
question, but before I'm going to ask
you that, I want to remind our viewers
at home how you can participate with
this program. You can do so one of three
ways. The first way, you can email us
your questions to bibleqa@3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa@3abn.tv.
Or for those of you who'd like to text
us, you can text us to 618-228-3975.
That's 618-228-3975.
And then for those of you who are on
Instagram, you can send us your
questions that way as well at
3abn_official,
at 3abn_official.
All right, brother. Here we go for your
first question.
We all have free will,
including the angels.
Can God's angels sin?
That's from Mary who emailed that to us.
Well, thank you, Mary, for that
question.
Uh
The angels that dwell in heaven right
now are absolutely,
categorically, unwilling to sin.
Um and I want to qualify that statement
because the angels do possess free will.
If you remember, uh at the foot of Mount
Sinai,
um
when Moses was up on the mountain,
and he was talking to God,
Aaron below had been coerced by the
mixed multitude to fashion a golden calf
to be represented as their god.
And when the Lord told told Moses to go
down from the mountain,
because as he said, the people were
committing a great sin. Once Moses got
down, and he saw that the people were in
open rebellion, the following took took
place. Exodus chapter 32 verse 26 says,
"Then Moses stood in the the entrance of
the camp, and said, 'Whoever is on the
Lord's side, come to me.'"
And all the sons of Levi gathered
themselves together to him. You see, a
dividing line was irrevocably placed
between those who chose to side with the
Lord, and then those who chose to remain
in rebellion.
And this was a repeat of what took
place, as the Bible describes it, in
heaven long ago.
In Revelation chapter 12, starting in
verse 7, it says, "And war broke out in
heaven. Michael and his angels fought
with the dragon, and the dragon and his
angels fought, but they did not prevail,
nor was a place found for them in heaven
any longer." Now, why was there no place
found for Satan and his angels in heaven
any longer?
Jude chapter 1 verse 6 says, "And I
remind you of the angels who did not
stay within the limits of authority God
gave them, but left the place where they
belonged, God has kept them securely
chained in prisons of darkness waiting
for the great day of judgment." So, as
you stated, they chose to rebel, they
chose to fight against Christ and his
angels, and they chose to leave heaven.
And these were all free will choices.
The same is true concerning the angels
who decided to remain in heaven. Like
the Levites at Sinai, they chose to
remain loyal to God. They chose to stand
with Christ against the rebellion,
and they chose to remain with him in
heaven.
Once again, these are all free will
choices.
And when the angels were cast out, every
angel had been given ample opportunity
to decide which side they wanted to give
their willing, permanent allegiance to.
And when the Bible says in Revelation
chapter 12 verse 9, "So, the great
dragon was cast out, that serpent of old
called the devil and Satan, who deceives
the whole world, he was cast to the
earth, and his angels were cast out with
him." It signifies that every angel who
was not cast out was sealed in their
decision to remain righteous, loyal, and
obedient to God and His law.
And note that this loyalty was based on
their love to God.
How do we know this? Because they chose
to obey God. For the Bible says in
Romans chapter 13 verse 10, "Love does
no harm to a neighbor, therefore love is
the fulfillment of the law."
So, all the way back then, the loyal
angels learned a lesson that we as a
race are still trying to learn today,
namely the lesson of of knowing how to
possess divine godly love.
And not only loving God supremely, but
also learning to love one another.
Remember that the fallen angels fought
not only with Christ, but they also
fought with the loyal angels. So, they
had no love for God, nor for one
another. And so, the loyal angels, uh
can they sin?
The Bible is clear that because they
made a conscious choice to give their
permanent allegiance to God, Psalm 119
verse 165 says, "Great peace have those
who love your law, and nothing causes
them to stumble, because they truly love
God's law without reservation."
Amen. Thank you very much for that
answer, brother.
Okay, Pastor Dinzey, I've got your first
question.
Why was David wrong to count the
Israelites in 1 Chronicles? That's from
Sophia who emailed that to us.
Uh thank you, Sophia. That's a good
question.
And sometimes the sin lies in the motive
behind the act. Uh give me an example is
Cain offered a sacrifice, but there was
the wrong motive. He offered the wrong
sacrifice. Uh we also have a time when
Saul
was uh waiting for Samuel, the prophet,
to arrive in order to offer sacrifice
before they engaged in in war, in
battle.
And Samuel, the prophet, was delayed,
and Saul was impatient, and he decided
to take it upon himself to offer
sacrifice. The wrong motive
caused this problem. You can see that
God ordered Moses to number the people
of Israel, and that's in Numbers chapter
1.
And when God says to do something, then
there is a good reason to do it.
Now, let's go ahead and take a look at
what happens with David. You see, in 1
Chronicles chapter 18, 19, and 20, what
we see here is that David was blessed
with great victories over other nations.
Uh 1 Chronicles chapter 18, for example,
verse 1.
"Now, after this, it came to pass that
David smote the Philistines and subdued
them, and took Gath and her towns out of
the hand of the Philistines."
Verse 2, "And he smote Moab, and the
Moabites became David's servants, and
brought gifts."
Uh look at now verse 5. "David slew of
the Syrians 2 and 20,000 men."
And then David put garrisons in the Siri
Syria Damascus, and the Syrians became
David's servants and brought gifts. Thus
the Lord preserved David whithersoever
he went.
But it it appears that as time goes on,
David begins to think, "I'm a mighty
warrior."
And he wants to know, "How many soldiers
do I have?" Because in those days, you
could bring fear upon other people when
you say, "We have 300,000 men ready to
fight against you. Give, you know, just
give up."
So, he appears to want to know, "Hey,
how many soldiers we have? We want to
put fear upon the people." And this is
why when we go into 1 Chronicles chapter
21, let's take a look beginning in verse
1. "Now, Satan stood up against Israel
and moved David to number Israel." So,
this was a
a a an enticement from the devil.
"So, David said to Joab, to the leaders
of the people, 'Go, number Israel from
Beersheba to Dan, and bring the number
of them to me that I may know it.'"
And Joab answered, "May the Lord make
His people 100 times more than they are.
But my lord, the king,
are they not all my lord's servants? Why
then does my lord require this thing?
Why should he be a cause of guilt in
Israel? David was hearing God's voice
through the through Joab. Nevertheless
Nevertheless the king's word prevailed
against Joab. Therefore Joab departed
and went throughout all Israel and came
to Jerusalem. So it was the motive
behind this that it became sin for David
to do this. Mhm. Amen. Yes. Thank you,
sir.
All right, Ian. Yes, sir.
>> Here's your first question.
Can you please explain 1 Timothy chapter
4 verses 3 through 5?
Does this mean we can eat any type of
flesh as long as we bless or pray over
it?
I know about the clean meats in
Deuteronomy chapter 14. I'm confused. It
seems to be a contradiction and that was
emailed to us. All right. Thank you so
much for this question and I'm actually
really glad that you emailed this in
because we covered this in our school of
discipleship here at 3ABN these very
verses. So what I'm going to do with you
is for the sake of time because I can't
cover them as well as I would like to as
opposed to in the classroom. I'm going
to go through five words that have very
important meanings in these verses. Now
the five words that we're going to break
down is abstain, meats, created,
creature, and sanctified. Now as you
read these verses starting in verse 3
that first word that I just talked about
abstain simply just means to refrain.
And the way that I'm getting the
translation of these words is by using a
Strong's Concordance. So you can do this
at home and I encourage you to do it at
home as well. Now the next word that
we're going to look at is meats. Now
meat simply translates into food and you
can um look also into Genesis chapter 1
verses 29 and 30 that also verifies
this. Now in Genesis chapter 1 verses 29
and 30 it says and God said behold I
have given you every herb bearing seed
which is upon the face of all the earth
and every tree in which is the fruit of
the tree yielding seed to you it shall
be for meat. And then it goes on to say
in verse 30 I have given you every green
herb for meat. So the word meat here
doesn't simply talk about flesh food.
It's also talking about as we've read
herbs, seeds, and fruits also can be
considered meat. So God has given us a
diet other than flesh food and has also
given us a non-meat diet. Now the next
one that we're going to look at is the
word created. Now the word created here
simply means to fabricate, found, or
formed originally. So what type of food
did God fabricate, found, or form
originally? Well as we just read it's
herbs, seeds, and nuts. We often call
this the Genesis diet. And
research and studies have shown that a
vegetarian diet can have some profound
health benefits if done properly. Now in
verse 4 the next word that we're going
to look at is creature. Creature
translates to original formation. And
then lastly in verse 5 the word that
we're going to look at is sanctified
which means to make holy, purify, or to
consecrate. So now when you take all of
these words and you have now derived
what the Strong's Concordance translates
them into. Now what I'm going to do is
read from verse 1 cuz I want you to get
the whole context of this. So I'm going
to read everything but I'm also going to
use the words that we just translated.
Now it says Now the spirit speaketh
expressly. I'm reading in the King James
version. That in the latter times some
shall depart from the faith giving heed
to seducing spirits and doctrines of
devils speaking lies and hypocrisy
having their conscience seared with a
hot iron. Now verse 3 forbidding to
marry and commanding to refrain from
food which God hath formed originally to
be received with thanksgiving of them
which believe and know the truth. For
every original formation of God is good
and nothing is to be refused if it be
received with thanksgiving for it is
made holy by the word of God and prayer.
Now one thing I also want to touch on is
who is the one who is speaking to us and
teaching us this? It's the spirit. It
says the spirit speaketh expressly. The
spirit is being outspoken about this and
teaching us. And if you look around as
the verse started off it says that in
latter times look around in today. We
know that we are living in the latter
times and what the Holy Spirit is
telling us and trying to bring us back
to is God's original diet and God's
original plan. And vegetarianism if you
look at the statistics has skyrocketed
over the last several years and it's no
surprise because meat, poultry, and fish
has become terribly infected with many
diseases, bacterial, parasitic, viral,
even some more severe diseases like mad
cow disease. So when you read 1 Timothy
4 3 and 5 in its full biblical and
linguistic setting it's not teaching
that prayer transform anything that we
choose to eat into something that God
approves. And this isn't legalism or
salvation by diet. It's simply
stewardship and discernment and trusting
in God that he also desires us as it
says in 3 John verse 2
it says that he wants us to prosper and
be in health even as our soul
prospereth. Amen. Amen. Great answer.
Thank you for sharing that.
All right, brother Darrell. Here's your
second question.
My extended family gets together every
year around Christmas time.
They understand that I'm an Adventist
but the event is usually on Saturday.
Should I attend or not?
I feel that if I don't attend I'll miss
opportunities to share my faith but at
the same time I want to keep the Sabbath
holy. That's from Sandy in Alabama who
emailed that question to us.
You know sister Sandy I've been in your
shoes before. Um I know it's hard to
make these types of choices especially
when it concerns our family members.
On one hand you want to please God. You
don't want to offend God but at the same
time you don't want to offend your loved
ones.
And then I also understand what it's
like when you observe the Sabbath how
sometimes it can make you feel different
or isolated especially from family.
But you know who else understands? Jesus
understands exactly what you're going
through as well. You see he's Lord of
the Sabbath
and he made it his mission to not only
bring attention to the Sabbath but also
teach us how it ought to be kept.
And it's not to be kept in selfishness
but it's to be kept in sacredness and
service.
Now regarding your question you stated
that this gathering usually occurs on
the Sabbath.
Now to them Saturday may just be a day
off from work or maybe some of them may
go to church on Sunday. So Saturday just
seems like the most convenient day to
hold such a gathering.
I grew up with this same mindset
um this same understanding
until one day I was convinced that the
following scripture passage was
addressed to me personally.
The words of this passage say remember
the Sabbath day to keep it holy. Exodus
20 verse 8.
So then what was once merely Saturday
became the Sabbath a period of holy
sacred time on the seventh day of the
week.
Scripture shows that Jesus
was active on the Sabbath.
He was doing his father's business among
those he loved, those who were in need.
See Matthew chapter 12 where the man
with the withered hand was healed. See
Luke chapter 13 where the woman who was
bent over for some time she was healed.
Then John chapter 5 where the paralytic
was healed and the list goes on. Jesus
was accustomed to mingling with the
people on the Sabbath
for the sake of freeing souls from
bondage.
Yet in light of your situation the
following passage is the reason why I
would choose not to attend during
Sabbath hours.
Given that your family knows that you
are Adventist and that the event is
consistently planned for Saturdays or
for for the Sabbath I believe the
counsel of Isaiah 58 fits very well
right here and I'll read from the NLT
version
for clarity.
Starting in verse 13 of Isaiah 58 it
says
keep the Sabbath day holy.
Don't pursue your own interests on that
day but enjoy the Sabbath and speak of
it with delight as the Lord's holy day.
Honor the Sabbath in everything you do
on that day and don't follow your own
desires or talk idly.
Verse 14 says then the Lord will be your
delight. I will give you the great I
will give you great honor and satisfy
you with the inheritance I promised to
your ancestor Jacob. I the Lord have
spoken.
So if you choose not to attend as I
would have chosen not to attend maybe
you can let them know that you love them
but explain to them your convictions.
And then you leave the outcome in the
hands of Jesus the Lord of the Sabbath
who made the Sabbath not just for you,
not just for me, but for all mankind
according to Mark chapter 2 verse 27.
Amen. Amen. Thank you for that answer,
brother. Very good.
Okay, Pastor Danzie.
Here's your second question.
After Cain left the presence of God in
Genesis chapter 4
who gave birth to the woman that he
married?
We Were there other humans in the world
apart from Adam, his wife, and Cain?
That's from Julia who emailed that to
us.
Thank you, Julia. That is my mother's
name also.
Thank [clears throat] you. Uh when we
look in the book of Genesis we see that
God created
Adam and Eve, male and female. There is
no record of any other human beings
being created. All other human beings
that came into existence came into
existence through procreation, that is
through Adam and Eve coming together.
So, who is this woman that Cain married?
Uh the Lord told Adam and Eve that they
should be fruitful and multiply. We have
to understand that this was Cain's
sister that he married when the time
came that his sister was old enough and
could bear children.
Let's go ahead and take a quick look at
some verses that help us to clarify
that.
And so in the book of Genesis, we are
moving
into verse actually chapter 5
and let's go to verse 1.
This is the book of the genealogy of
Adam.
In the day that God created man, he made
him in the likeness of God.
He created them male and female and
blessed them and called them mankind in
the day they were created.
Notice, and Adam lived 130
years
and begat a son in his own likeness
after his own image
and named him Seth. Seth was the one
that replaced Cain. So, how many years
passed? 130 years.
And so that is enough time for Adam to
have
sons and daughters. Notice what it says,
after he begat Seth, the days of Adam
were 830 years and he begat he has sons
and daughters. So, all the days of Adam
lived were 930 years and he died. So,
there were other children born after
Cain and Abel.
The Bible does not tell you each one of
the children that were born because how
big will would the Bible be if every
detail was placed in there?
>> [snorts]
>> What happens is that when Cain and Abel
were old to offer sacrifices on their
own, Cain kills Abel.
And so enough time had passed, 130 years
that
Seth was born. So, we should understand
that when Seth becomes the one to
replace Cain,
there were already 130 years that
passed. So, we should come to the
conclusion safely that okay, Seth was
born Now, when did God replace Cain?
Well, 130 years. And that either that
same year or the year before
Cain killed Abel. So, 130 years is
enough time for Adam and Eve to have
many, many children. We don't know how
many they had, but Cain from one of his
own sisters picked a wife. There was no
other choice. And so this is
the best and safest conclusion. Mhm,
amen. Thank you, brother. Thank you.
All right. And here's your second
question.
Do the fallen angels have the same
powers, abilities, and knowledge as the
angels in heaven? That's from Mike in
Michigan who emailed that to us. All
right, Mike. Thank you for your
question. Now, very simply, no, they do
not because they are limited and subject
to God. They are no longer protected by
God. Now, I believe Darrell read them
already, so I'm not going to read them
again. It was Revelation 12:7-9 where it
talks about how they were cast out of
heaven. Now, they lost their place. They
lost their position in heaven and they
no longer have God's protection.
Heavenly angels act on God's authority
and power, but evil angels or demons do
not. Now,
I want to say though that we still deal
with a very formidable foe.
These evil angels or these demons we
read about in Ephesians chapter 6 and
verse 12 where it says, "For we do not
wrestle against flesh and blood, but
against principalities, against powers,
against the rulers of the darkness of
this age, against spiritual hosts of
wickedness in heavenly places." And as
you continue to read on in Ephesians,
we're told that we have to put on the
armor of God. So, that means we have to
suit up. We have to do battle against
these demons and against these bad
angels. So, there's there's a they are a
formidable foe as like I said. If you
read in 1 Samuel chapter 16:14-15,
you actually see that these evil angels
in started to influence Saul and his
emotions and his mood. It says that Saul
had an evil spirit come upon him. And
the reason why that happened is because
God withdrew his protection from Saul
because Saul continued to reject God and
which then gave evil angels access and
influence over Saul. So, these evil
angels or demons then like I said began
to influence his mood
maybe with anxiety and fear, possibly
even depression. So, these
evil angels can affect us and our moods
or try to influence us, I should say.
Try to.
Then you could also read about the
demoniac in Mark chapter 5, also in Luke
chapter 8 where this demoniac was given
superhuman strength. They tried to bind
him in chains and shackles and they
could not hold him. And often they would
find him and hear him screaming in the
in these tombs and he would be cutting
himself. So, demons can actually cause
us to act mentally insane. They could
really try to influence us and maybe
even have us physically hurt ourselves.
And part of your question also asked if
they could have the same knowledge. Now,
well, they do have that what I will say
is that they do not have full knowledge.
They've been around for thousands and
thousands of years. They've seen how
humans interact, behaviors and patterns.
So, they could possibly try to predict
of what could take place, but these
predictions aren't always true. Evil
angels may seem to have comparable
knowledge, but their knowledge is only
based on observation. It is not by
divine revelation.
And as we often see in the Bible and and
in our own lives, evil angels mix truth
with error. But there's something that I
want to leave you with and and that is
important that you remember. Evil
angels, demons, they fear and obey the
commands of Jesus. Luke chapter 4:25,
they obey without any resistance. In
Luke chapter 8 and verse 31, they begged
not to be destroyed. In Mark chapter
3:11, they fell and bowed in before
Jesus in recognition of him and his
authority. So, remember, they serve a
different master and their allegiance is
to Satan and they and even he is subject
to God's authority, but our God, our
master stands alone and there is none
like him. Mhm, amen. Amen. Very good
answer. Thank you, sir.
>> Amen.
All right, Darrell, I got your next
question, but let me remind our viewers
at home how you can participate with
this program. You can do so one of three
ways. You can email us your questions to
bibleqa@3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa@3abn.tv.
Or you can text us to 618-228-3975.
That's 618-228-3975.
Or for those of you on Instagram,
@3abn_official.
All right, Darrell, here we go.
If there was no sin in the beginning,
why did God ask Cain and Abel to bring
him a sacrifice? That's from Noreen who
emailed that to us.
That's a great question and
uh
God's request that Cain and Abel should
bring him a sacrifice wasn't an
arbitrary request from God. Romans
chapter 3
verse 23 tells us that all have sinned
and come short of the glory of God.
So, where in human history did this
trail of sin begin?
Well, to put it plainly,
it began in the beginning.
Uh but like you said, it didn't begin
right at creation when the Bible says
everything was perfect.
Um but it began at some point in the
Bible shortly after creation where the
Bible says in Romans chapter 5:12,
"Through one man sin entered the world
and death through sin and thus death
spread to all men because all sinned."
And then the Bible says in Romans
chapter 6:23
that the wages of sin is death.
And so this is not just referring to the
kind of this death in in Romans chapter
6:23 is not just referring to the type
of death that Adam and his descendants
have died since he first sinned, which
Jesus likened in John chapter 11:11 to
an unconscious sleep state.
Um but uh because of Adam's sin, the
human race by following Adam's in Adam's
footsteps would also be doomed to perish
in what Revelation chapter 20:14 calls
the second death.
This death
will be eternal.
And to prevent this death, this second
death, God initiated a special plan.
We see the first glimmer of this when
the Bible says in Genesis chapter 3:21,
"Unto Adam also and to his wife did the
Lord make coats of skins and clothed
them." This means that God performed the
very first sacrifice.
An animal had to lay down its life so
that Adam and his wife, who had hastily
clothed themselves with fig leaves,
so that they could be
uh instead of the fig leaves, so that
they could be covered with something
better.
The Bible says in Romans chapter 5:17,
"For the sin of this one man, Adam,
caused death to rule over many, but even
greater is God's wonderful grace
and his gift of righteousness for all
who receive it will live in triumph over
sin and death through this one man,
Jesus Christ."
>> Amen.
When Adam ate of the forbidden fruit,
Christ, the creator and the perfect son
of God, had already decided that he
would come to this world in human flesh
to legally take upon him our filth, our
sin, our penalty so that we could be
clothed with his righteous life and
character
through the power of the Holy Spirit.
This mirrors God's removal of the fig
leaves and replaces it with with new
clothing.
And replacing it with new clothing. Adam
taught this truth to his sons. Thus, we
see that when Cain and Abel brought
their sacrifice, there was a special
purpose in play. It was designed to
bring human minds
to the attention that Christ's sacrifice
would be for their sins in the future.
And so, for um as I said, the wages of
sin is death.
But praise God that the gift of God is
eternal life in Jesus Christ our Lord.
Amen. Amen. Thank you, sir.
All right.
Pastor Danzie, here's your third
question.
From a Baptist sister curious about
Sabbath.
How should I properly keep the Sabbath
holy?
What activities should I avoid on this
day and how can I truly delight in it as
God intended? That's from Sandra in New
York.
Thank you very much, sister Sandra. We
already had some information about this
a few questions ago, but let's go ahead
and
see how we can
be of help.
Uh actually, your question requires more
time than I'm allowed. How else to say
that?
In Exodus chapter 20, verses 8 through
11, I I like to talk first about the
delight part because the
people don't like things that are don't
do this, don't do that. But let's go
with the delight first.
Exodus 20, verses 8 through 11. Remember
the Sabbath day to keep it holy. Six
days you shall labor and do all your
work. But the seventh day is the Sabbath
of the Lord your God. In it you shall do
no work, nor you, nor your son, nor your
daughter, nor your male servant, nor
your female servant, nor your cattle,
nor your stranger who is within your
gates. For in six days the Lord made the
heavens and the earth, the sea, and all
that is in them.
And rested the seventh day. Therefore,
the Lord blessed the Sabbath day and
hollowed it. We're talking about the
seventh day, which is Saturday. So, the
Lord blessed this day and it is holy.
He made it holy after right after
creation and it continues to be holy
until he takes that holiness away, which
he will not do because what the Lord
does, he does forever. Amen. The seventh
day Sabbath is holy forever.
Now, what can you do to delight in it?
Rest from your work just as we read in
this commandment found in Exodus chapter
20, verses 8 through 11. And I would
encourage you take a prayerful look at
God's fourth commandment. Read it
several times. Ask the Lord to give you
a a a greater understanding of it so
that you
can understand more and delight in the
Sabbath day. So, what can you do? Let's
take take a look at Matthew chapter 11,
verses 28 through 30 because this is
part of what you can do on the Sabbath.
Jesus says, "Come to me, all you who
labor and are heavy laden and I will
give you rest.
Take my yoke upon you and learn from me,
for I am gentle and lowly in heart and
you will find rest for your souls, for
my yoke is easy and my burden is light.
So,
yes, on all the other days you can come
to Jesus, but on the seventh day
Sabbath, when you don't have any work,
those type of responsibilities and
stress, coming to Jesus is a time that
you can delight in his presence. How can
you delight in the Sabbath day? Delight
in the presence of the Lord. You have no
pending, oh, I got to go to work.
Uh you have you don't have that. So,
learn of Jesus. Well, learn of Jesus.
What did Jesus do? Luke 4:16 says, "And
he, Jesus,
came to Nazareth where he had been
brought up and as his custom was, he
went into the synagogue on the Sabbath
day and stood up for to read." So,
learning from Jesus is
go to church on the seventh day Sabbath.
Have a holy convocation. The Bible calls
this a holy convocation when you look
there in the book of uh Leviticus and
Numbers,
a holy convocation we are to have on the
Sabbath day.
So, specially on the Sabbath day, seek
the rest that Jesus offers.
And there is the Bible. Yes, delight in
reading God's word with uh what you
would call either with a group, but
spend time alone with God's word and ask
the Lord to draw you closer to him as
you delight in reading his word.
And uh the Bible uh is a book
that has no no book that can compare to
it. There is another book that I want to
recommend to you.
It is called the book of nature. That's
not a physical book. It is out there in
nature, God's creation. This is a time
when you can enjoy God's creation. I
have very little time left to tell you
what not to do, but one of the things
you should not do is go shopping on the
Sabbath day. Why? Because
you are going into an area that can
cause you harm.
You can read about this in the book of
Nehemiah. In the book of Nehemiah, it
gives us an understanding that you
should not be purchasing things on the
Sabbath day. Nehemiah chapter 13, that
is all we have for for today, for now.
Amen. Thank you, sir.
All right. Ian, here's your third
question.
I often hear people say that everyone is
a child of God. I don't believe that
because I know some people choose not to
be his child. If everyone were a child
of God, wouldn't that mean that everyone
would be saved? That's from Hazel in
Maryland who emailed that to us. Yeah,
thank you, Hazel. This is a really
important question and one I know that
is very commonly asked cuz we hear that
phrase, we're all children of God. And
it sounds very loving,
um but the Bible they it defines this
phrase and scripture makes an important
distinction because we know we are all
created by God, but being considered a
child of God is different. Um
Joshua chapter 24 and verse 15 says,
"Choose you this day whom you will
serve." So, we all have a choice that we
have to make. And one thing that you're
going to find a little bit interesting
is we actually have a choice between two
fathers. Jesus even made a distinction
between this because in John chapter
8:44, he says, "You are of the father
you are of your father the devil and the
lusts of your father you want to do."
So, you can actually be choosing to
follow after the wrong father and that
being that of the devil.
So, it's pretty clear there. We also in
order we have to receive Christ into our
lives to be considered children of God.
We have to choose him. John chapter 1,
verses 12 and 13 says, "But as many as
received him, to them he gave power to
do what? Become the sons of God." Even
to them that believe in his name, which
were born not of blood, nor of the will
of flesh, nor of the will of man, but of
God. So, John chapter 1, 12 and 13 tells
us that becoming a child of God is
something that we receive. It's a choice
that we make. It's a transition from
from one former state to another. And
scripture even explains a former
condition that we had or that we would
have if have we not chosen because it
says that we are children of wrath. You
can read that in Ephesians chapter 2 and
verse 3. And then in just a few chapters
later, Jesus even tells Nicodemus that
we are to be born again. So, why would
we need to be born again? Because that
new birth is only necessary if we were
not already part of God's family.
Through faith in Christ, our
relationship with God changes where we
become children of wrath to becoming
children of God. And that born again
process begins in our baptism and in our
faith in Jesus Christ. Galatians chapter
3, verses 26 and 27. "For ye are all the
children of God by faith in Christ
Jesus. For as many of you as been
baptized into Christ have put on
Christ." So, while God is the creator of
all, the Bible teaches us that in order
to become his child, we have to choose
him. We have to do that through faith.
We have to do that through relationship
with Christ. We have to do that when we
receive him into our life. Because think
about it, if we are calling ourselves
children of God, then we would have his
name. We would have his character. We
would be acting in accordance to how he
wants us to act, which is, you know, you
can read the fruit of the spirit.
All of these things is evidence to know
that we have God in our lives and that
we are all that we are all truly a child
of God.
Amen. Thank you, brother. Amen.
All right. Brother Darrell, here's your
last question.
Why did Jesus convert Saul, who later
switched to Paul, but not convert
Caiaphas as well? That's from John in
Georgia who emailed that to us.
Thanks, John, for that question. And
Jesus didn't convert Paul by force.
>> [laughter]
>> Nor did he prevent Caiaphas from being
converted by force.
You see, Paul repented and Caiaphas
refused to repent. Both received light,
but only one accepted it. But let's
unpack this.
In Acts chapter 9, Paul had a miraculous
visionary encounter with Jesus and he
knew it was Jesus because in verse 4 and
5, he said to Paul, "Saul, Saul, why are
you persecuting me? I am Jesus whom you
are persecuting. It is hard for you to
kick against the goads."
Paul, who had been temporarily blinded
by this encounter, made his way to a
house and there he prayed according to
verse 11.
Meanwhile, a disciple by the name of
Ananias
was told to go to find Paul and this is
what happened next in verses 17 to 18.
It says, "And Ananias went his way and
entered the house, and laying his hands
on him, he said, 'Brother Saul, the Lord
Jesus, who appeared to you on the road
as you came, has sent me that you may
receive your sight and be filled with
the Holy Spirit.' Immediately there fell
from his eyes something like scales, and
he received his sight at once, and he
arose and was baptized." You see, Paul
prayed in repentance as he waited, and
he was baptized once Ananias arrived.
And so, he chose to be converted.
Meanwhile, Caiaphas also met Jesus
face-to-face, in person.
Jesus had been accused by false
witnesses and had remained silent the
whole time until the high priest said,
in Matthew chapter 26 verse 63 and 64,
"I put you under oath by the living God.
Tell us if you are the Christ, the Son
of God." Jesus said to him, "It is as
you said. Nevertheless, I say to you,
hereafter you will see the Son of Man
sitting on the right hand of the power
and coming on the clouds of heaven."
You see, Caiaphas, who had received a
clear answer about the divinity of Jesus
from Jesus himself,
did not repent.
Instead, he accused Jesus of blasphemy
and let out in condemning him to death.
And after Jesus ascended to heaven,
Caiaphas still persecuted the disciples
of Jesus.
Conversely, on the other hand, instead
of continuing to resist, Paul later
reflected on his conversion experience
saying, in Galatians 2:20,
"I have been crucified with Christ. It
is no longer I who live, but Christ
lives in me. And the life which I now
live in the flesh, I live by faith in
the Son of God who loved me and gave
himself for me."
But Caiaphas, just like Cain, just like
Haman, Korah, Dathan, Abiram, and Judas,
he continued to resist and persecute
Christ and his followers until it was
forever too late. Mhm. Wow, very sad.
Yes. Thank you, brother, for sharing
that.
Pastor Dan, here's your final question.
Do you have to be baptized in water to
be saved?
I would love to be baptized in water.
Where I live, there isn't any church
that I like or attend. So, I watch
Christian TV and read the Bible every
day.
I believe that Jesus died for our sins
and was resurrected by God. That's from
Juanita, uh who emailed that to us.
Amen. Thank you, Juanita. I rejoice in
many things that you said, and we're
going to let the Bible answer your
question.
>> Amen. Uh it is important to understand
that uh everyone
has sinned and is short of the glory of
God. I praise the Lord that you're
reading the Bible. I praise the Lord
that you're interested in spiritual
things.
Uh when we look at John chapter 3 verse
5 and 6,
and I encourage you to read all of John
chapter 3. That's where you find John
3:16, that God so loved the world that
he gave his only begotten Son, that
whoever believes in him will not perish,
but have everlasting life. John
chapter 3 verse 5 and 6, Jesus answered,
"Most assuredly, I say to you, unless
one is born of water and the Spirit, he
cannot enter the kingdom of God. That
which is born of the flesh is flesh. And
that which is born of the Spirit is
spirit. So, we see here a very clear
indication that we should be baptized.
And so, what prevents you from being
baptized?
You know, today in in in today's modern
times, there is transportation. I
encourage you to find a place where you
can be baptized so that you can
enter into this union with God that as
the Bible says, if you're not born of
water and the Spirit, you cannot see the
kingdom of God. Now, there are extreme
cases, and I want to go into that in a
moment, but first let's look at Romans
chapter 6 verse 3 and 4.
Or do you not know that as many as of of
us as were baptized into Christ were
baptized into his death?
Therefore, we are buried with him
through baptism into death, that just as
Christ was raised from the dead by the
glory of the Father, even so we also
should walk in newness of life. So, this
baptism should be the baptism according
to the Bible because baptizo means to
submerge. So, a baptism according to the
Bible means that you must be put under
the water
and then brought back out as if you're
dying to sin and being born again in
Christ Jesus. Mhm. So, this is what true
baptism is.
A dying to a old way of life, and then
you walk in newness of life. Now, there
are extreme cases where people were not
baptized. We see, for example, the thief
on the cross. There's no record that he
was baptized.
Perhaps he was baptized before he was
put on the cross and then
uh fell into sin. We do not know. But
for those people that for some reason or
another cannot be baptized, I believe it
is safe to say that the baptism of Jesus
stands in the place for that person.
I've heard of people that uh they're in
the hospital, and there they accept the
Lord Jesus Christ, cannot be baptized
because of their condition, they're tied
to machines.
But
the baptism of Christ can stand for
them.
But if you are able to be baptized, I
encourage you to to um
search diligently and make this a living
experience in your life. Amen. Amen.
Thank you for that answer, Pastor.
All right, Ian, here's your last
question.
It's a long one here.
It says, "I have hurt someone who has
since passed away.
I had the opportunity to ask for
forgiveness, but I didn't out of shame
and because I
took the situation for granted.
Now, whenever I think of this person, it
deeply hurts me.
I often reflect on this in relation to
judgment and the salvation of my soul.
I have prayed and asked God to forgive
me,
but I never asked forgiveness from the
person themselves.
Will God forgive me?"
That's from Marissa, who emailed that to
us. Mhm. Marissa, thank you so much. Um
I can I can feel your heart in this
question and how you feel about it. Um
so, I want to just come out right from
the beginning and say yes, God can
forgive you.
>> Amen. Uh God's forgiveness is not
blocked by death. It's not blocked by
missed opportunities. Uh when confession
or or when confession and repentance is
real and sincere, his character is the
one that you rely on, not on our
feelings or emotions. His mercy is not
limited by circumstances uh that we can
no longer change. So, why then do we
still struggle with this fear that maybe
God can't forgive us forgive us? Cuz I
know there are many people out there
that might feel uh in different ways or
in different situations where you've
done something and you're just like,
"How can God forgive someone like me?"
And it's often because we carry just
this deep regret and the shame. We often
replay in our minds, you know, what we
should have done or what we could have
done and or what we failed to do. And
it's in those moments that we begin to
measure God's forgiveness not by our
feelings, but by his word. And by taking
a hold of his word and claiming those
promises because scripture reminds us in
1 John 1:9, "If we confess our sins, he
is faithful and just to forgive us of
our sins and to cleanse us of all
unrighteousness." In here, the scripture
doesn't say if we confess only to the
person that we have wronged or uh
doesn't say that we have to make amends
or that we have to restore what's been
broken and that's the only way God can
forgive us. I will say though, however,
the Bible does teach us that anytime
that we have hurt someone, we should
take those opportunities while we have
them because time is short. Uh so, I
don't want to to confuse this where you
don't have to do it because we should
make that opportunity to seek
reconciliation when it is possible. And
I know that you
uh in your question, you you that moment
passed. But um what I want you to do is
with you or I want to do with you is I
want to look at some biblical examples
where maybe some other people in the
Bible have shared something where they
could no longer ask for forgiveness. And
one of them is being that of David. Now,
David lusted after a woman whose name
was Bathsheba. And what happened was as
he laid with her and he ended up getting
her pregnant, and and she was married to
a man named Uriah. And what he did is he
sent Uriah then to the front lines of
battle to have him killed. Now,
unfortunately, Uriah was killed, and
David never had an opportunity to ask
for forgiveness. Um
but we know that the Bible says that
David was a was a man after God's own
heart. So, there it would seem like,
okay, how does that possible? Because
we're not relying on our own emotions,
our own mistakes, our own failures, and
maybe even some grotesque things in this
case where we have wronged somebody in
such a way where we have caused their
death. God still forgives. Saul, who was
later named Paul, think about it, he
persecuted all the followers of Christ,
uh imprisoned them, sanctioned their
deaths, but yet he had a a powerful
transformation experience, and yet God
still forgives him. And there are many
people who Paul had hurt, and he never
was able to ask for forgiveness and seek
reconciliation with them. And lastly,
think of those who even persecuted
Jesus, those who played a part in the
death of Jesus Christ. And we read in
Acts chapter 2 where Peter is giving the
sermon, and he calls them out saying,
"You crucified Christ. You are the ones
who did that." And the Bible tells us
that their hearts were pricked, and they
asked, "Well, what can we do?" And he
just says, "Repent and be baptized." So,
and we were also told that 3,000 were
added to the church that day. Now,
here's is verse that I want you to hold
on to as you struggle with this and it
comes from 2 Corinthians chapter 7 and
verse 10 and it says, "For godly sorrow
produces repentance leading to
salvation, not to be regretted, but the
sorrow of the world produces death."
Now, I can already tell in your question
that you have that heart that you wish
you could go back and take me, you know,
go back in time and ask for forgiveness,
but I want to give you hope and
encouragement not to rely on what may
could have been or your emotions or your
feelings. Rely on the word of God and
that he forgives you.
Amen. Amen. Thank you, brother. Amen.
Well, we've seen all these answers and
from the word of God and I was blessed
by that and I'm sure that you were as
well.
We're going to be taking a short break
here in a little bit, but let me tell
you something, there's some more
questions that you can get your answers
to on the website 3abn bibleanswers.com.
So, check out that website 3abn
bibleanswers.com.
We'll be right back, so don't go away.
If you're enjoying our 3abn Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word [music] to shed light on those
texts that seem difficult to understand.
To have your questions [music] answered
on a future program, just email them to
us at bibleqa@3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa@3abn.tv.
You may also text [music] your questions
to 618-228-3975.
That's 618-228-3975.
Be sure to include your name and where
you live and then watch 3abn Bible Q&A
for answers from God's word.
Thanks for coming back.
Going to get some final thoughts from
our panelists. So, brother Ian, I'll
start off with you. Yeah, I just wanted
to touch one more time on the last
question that I had because I know it's
something where many people struggle
with how can God forgive me? You know,
uh I wish I could go back. I should have
done this or I should have done that and
I just think it's so important for us to
not let those those thoughts or those
emotions come into us and I know it's a
battle that we all have to fight uh
sometimes, especially when we know we've
done something wrong. But, if you have
truly repented uh and confessed your sin
to God, he has forgiven you. Your
salvation does not rest on what you can
no longer change. It rests on the grace
of Christ. Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. Concerning the Sabbath, I do
want to say uh shopping online or
whether going to the stores, that is
something that we can see near my bed
should not be done. But, I want to say
something to you that can be done and
that is as it says in Mark chapter 3,
Jesus says, "It is lawful to do good on
the Sabbath day." Mhm. And there are
many good things the Lord can guide you
to do on the Sabbath day. Amen. Amen.
Amen. And uh regarding the question from
sister Sandy about family gatherings on
the Sabbath, I just want to let you know
that when you leave your your loved ones
in the in the hands of God, if you
choose not to attend, uh just know that
you're leaving your your loved ones in
the hands of somebody who wants to save
them probably more than you want to. And
so, they're in good hands, so don't
worry. Amen. Amen.
Well, thank you, gentlemen, for your
participation and sharing with us from
the word of God. And thank you for
joining us. I hope that you will come
back next time, but until we meet again,
I want to leave you with this fun
scripture song and encourage you to
memorize God's word and hide it in your
heart. So, here's a good one for you.
You shall love the Lord your God with
all your heart, with all your soul and
with all your strength. You shall love
the Lord your God with all your heart,
with all your soul and with all your
strength. Deuteronomy 6:5. Deuteronomy
6:5.
Thanks and we'll see [music] you again
next time. God bless.